Now such applications are what are called
N-tier applications because if you look at the
software stack that comprises an application such
as this, you'll see several different layers. You
have a presentation layer. And the presentation
layer is the one that is responsible for
painting the screen on your browser. Perhaps
dynamically generating the page based on the request
you made. And there may be application
logic that corresponds to what the service is
providing. And there is business logic that
corresponds to the way airfares are decided, seats
are allocated, all these kinds of things.
And there's a database layer that accesses the
database that contains information about all the things
that the application and the business logic have
to decide on in order to satisfy a
particular request. And all these different layers have
to worry about many of the issues that
we're already familiar with, in the context of writing,
parallel programs and distributive programs, and those include
persistence for actions. For example, let's say I
made a choice, but I haven't completed the
booking. I may go away and come back later
on, in order to complete that booking. So
persistence is something that I might need. You
need a notion of transaction because I have
initiated a particular operation and I have not
completed it and so transaction properties may be
needed in order to make sure that a
reservation that started Is finally complete and I
have made the booking. Caching of data that you
pulled in from a database server so
that you can access the database more quickly.
Clustering, which corresponds to taking a set of
related services and clustering it together in order
to improve the performance of the service. And
similarly clustering the data that you're accessing from
a data base server. All of these are issues, and of course one of the things
that we worry about a lot this days in Ecommerce is security, in particular when
we are communicating financial information, credit card information,
and personal information like social security Id's and
so on We worry a lot about services provided by the server and that my personal
information is not compromised in any fashion. So
these are all the sets of issues that
N-tier Applications have to worry about in
making sure that the services it provides
are trustworthy from an end user's point of view. So, how do we structure an
N-tier application like this? The things that we want to reduce is reduce the
amount of network communication because that results
in latency, reduce security risks for the users
which means that the business logic should
not be compromised. And increase the concurrency for
handling an individual request. For instance, there's
an individual request, but in processing this request,
there's an opportunity to exploit parallelism. Often
times, these are called embarrassingly parallel applications because
even though this request seems like a
single request, there's an opportunity to exploit parallelism.
And the kind of parallelism is embarrassingly parallel
because the same query. I want to find out
the availability of seats on a particular date.
I don't care about which airline I go by.
That's an opportunity for parallelism for the expedia
server, to go in parrallel to multiple airlines and
find out the availability of seats on the
dates that I requested. Similarly, there's opportunity for exploiting
concurrency across several simultaneous requests that are coming in. And
also for clustering the computation that may have to be done on the server for
computations that are common across simultaneously
arriving requests. We want to reuse components aggressively.
By components we mean portions of the application logic that can be reused
in constructing these applications as well as
in the execution of the components in
order to service the requests that are
coming in simultaneously from several different clients.